how does the
prison
system well i mean is there a prison or
is it just forced labor camps and death
so there are three types of prison camps
in north korea and there's two types of
crime too
so one is political crime
and second is economic crime so even you
rape somebody or murder somebody i mean
by the way rave is not even crime in
north korea you don't even know what
rape is like if there's somebody raped
like that girl gets punished right they
it's
i mean men have a pleasure squad like we
don't even know that sexual harassment
is a thing
so
like that's not even crime so let's say
murder
murderers even like gets economic
crime because you've taken a worker away
from the party
but then that's they don't even punish
that much because human life doesn't
mean much in that country we don't even
know what human rights is but most
severe crime is a political crime like
let's say your house cut off caught on
fire you have your children your mother
all like sleeping next to you
but you have a portrait of kim's every
household have the portrait of kim's so
what do you do in the house get caught
fire you don't want your children on
your arms you have to protect the
portraits otherwise the regeneration of
that family get punished
or like if there's a newspaper every
newspaper front page you gotta have the
photos of kim's but when you didn't see
that and i used the back of the paper
and you reap it by mistake
that's when you go to political prison
camp
and that's a life sentence you never
kill them out and then you take three
generations of your family with you
so they are like concentration camps
that is a lifetime sentence
then there is a uh
labor camps that is more like the
murderers of thieves
or like you know criminal citizen that
is like a user sentence you come up the
last one is the labor camp uh forced
labor camp that's a
more i mean re-education camp those are
more like one between three years short
amount of sentence
and then of course there's a public
execution for somebody who cannot be
with him just they're gonna kill them
anyway
so usually those if somebody say oh i
don't believe in the party it's like
revolution ideology then that person get
executed and the family members usually
go to concentration camps
and then they never come out
and the north korea needs this
construction kept like inmates because
they do a lot of the
the chemical tests you know there's gap
chambers but north korea does a lot of
bio
is you know weapons so they need they
use like inmates
and you know do the orders test on them
and then they they have to clean the
nuclear debris
so you know they get deformative and
they die from a cancer so they keep
creating these political prisoners to do
all this job that they don't want the
normal population to be exposed to
well it's not just the public executions
that are executions then there's a lot
of other ways that you can be forced to
die
yeah in these different levels of of
prison
i lose your lifespan when you sent
political prison camp is three months
most of them do not last more than three
months
yeah so
when you go to political prison camp
it's better off to be signed right now
so that's why when defectors escaping
myself
uh we were ready to kill ourselves
you're not gonna go stand back and be
tortured and go to consensus and die
that's the most
painful misery where you can die
he was so certain that you would have
gone back and you would have been killed
that it's just easier to take your own
life instead of suffer
it's not just certainly the north korean
regime what they say so if you go to
china
and then if you are trying to escape the
south korea that's that sentence that's
a public execution or concentration camp
like that's a law so we all know that
what the law says
so when north koreans actually escape
they're all like ready to kill
themselves thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace